Gamer's...
What's up? it's time for me, Pewdiepie, to play some more video games.
Look at this! Jesus Christ I'm fast... not (lol)
So this game is called Pablo. It's supposed to be like
It's supposed to be like counter-strike, but for for VR, did I grab that? Oh my god. Can I pick it up for ya?
I definitely have the controls figure it out. Okay, here we frickin go time to kill some noobs
Oh my god, how am I so fast? :0 It will
Shit wait, how do I buy some? on the vive? I think it's right on the--on the track pad
Shit, someone buy me a gun, please, please, please
Arvid please. Ah, geez. I guess we're going knifes style Arvin. Oh
Oh cool I have gun now
Thanks, Arvin. Okay, okay we got this just take it easy. I'm actually scared
Oh God...
Oh God. Oh!
Where's my teammates?
Okay, oh this is the same map as counter-strike, okay, okay, you're gonna mess with me boy!
That's my teammate, isn't it? Yeah. Okay, cool. Hey, hey. Hey
I need help
Bravo, thank you. There's a great clear. We're clear
All right, unless they're coming around. I'll make sure I'll cover your back. You're kind of camping dude (hes kinda not)
I mean, they're gonna come around the corner, I'm gonna kill em
Okay, oh I'm double K I'm camping for you yeah
Hey, look at that, look at that it works thanks to me. Oh god. Damn Oh, what do you do?
Put down the night put down the knife
Put it down, man. Okay. Okay good
Cool. I'm John. All right, finally have a gun
Oh...
All right. Well, I'm gonna go this way
AH!
AHHHH!
YEAAAAH! Get fucked bitch, *what?* (lol)
how do I reload?
Fuck. Drop it, drop it!
That's how we do it in Sweden, Oh God.
I'm--this is actually scary to play (its not)
Where'd they shoot?
Hey, look at that, did everything you're welcome guys. You're welcome
Trying to do a knife here team this time. Hey, did everyone has anyone ever told you you sound like jacksepticeye.
Oh really Wow. No, I headed never because they sound like markiplier
Let me uh stab this bot. Stop killing the bots guy:why? :(
It's a tactic.
What you're not even jerking them off dude, you got to do it over here
This is like he's like right here
Sorry Pewds, you're gonna die
Stop jacking people up. I got him
Oh
Yeah
That's how it's done. I got him you didn't boy
I killed literally. Oh, oh, oh really sure. You sound a lot like pewdiepie
I--I'm skeptical because I've been on your wall
I've been on the internet for a while
I'm just gonna say
Hey man, I really appreciate your content. You've gotten me through some tough times
and I respect the fu-- (best part by far)
*laughter*
You just shot him!
Okay Jim, come back here
Wow what the frick. can I get a gun, please? Yeah. Here you go.
guy: Oh, thanks. I got you, I got a lot of money
Okay, let's do this. We got shotguns
guy: Oh god, oh god, oh god, they're right around that corner
guy: Ummm, I got this
pewds: yeah go in, you go in first
Guy: He's right around the corner. How do I load this thing?
pewds: You got it pump it Oh load it yeah
Guy: Josie I gotta pewds: thank you. Yeah. Guy: There you go
pewds: Thank you so much
Oh god I'm out of ammo. I'm out of ammo!
Guy: I gochu! I gochu! Let's go! Let's go!
Oh yeah
Okay, for real how do I open the menu for for guns and shit?
Guy: Are you on a vive or rift?
Vive.
Umm well how do you do it?
It's on the right--on the right track pad for me.
Oh, yeah, I got it thank you let's hold this point again, yeah, it worked out really well oh yeah
I'm like shaking. I don't know why
Let's go let's go
Who the ---k shot me? Oh, I see. Okay now I should be able to buy
Now I have no money fuck
alright, knife time.
Pewds, can I get one "How's it going bros?"
pffft no
Is a double-barrel any good. At close range yes because you can stack them
They get glitchy when you reload but you can stack them so
you can just like pull them out
FUCK!
What's your favorite movie?
Uhh I don't know man. What's yours?
I would have to say umm the Clockwork Orange.
Oh we have the same one. Is that why you asked?
Oh, no. I actually didn't know
What the hell is this
Why'd you shoot it?
Why was I so-- HEY!
Why you shoot me?
Is anyone home? Is anyone home?
Hello. Hey. Hey, dad. Don't fucking shoot me again. I'll kill you.
Uh really well, I have a hammer.
Wait cover me one second. I lost my headphone
woah x6
Drop your gun! Drop it. Just drop it! You drop it. Drop it! Drop the gun
Don't worry I drop the grenade
Good call
me
Hey
It's supposed to be in the garage
Oh here it is
Hey hey sorry I didn't mean to stab you
He's moving, he's moving.
Yeah what are you gon--
I love this game
What the fuck are you doing?
Ay x7
Don't shoot. Don't shoot
Saved your life.
Thank you
Stand still x7
Come back here, I'm a tickle you
Tickle Wickle
Didn't
Where the fuck is it? Where is it?
Hey, gimme dat, gimme dat
What is wrong with you?
How could you just kill oh, yeah
Oh, yeah, that's right anyone else want some
Haha, hey
Yo
Yeah
Yep, nope, nope, nope. Nope god damn it
You're dead. Now. You came to the wrong hood. You can't Oh, what are you gonna do now? Hey, what the Frick? All right
Say you're sorry
Say you're sorry say you're
How damn it stop running oh
You try it again
Alright, that's it that's it for me playing Pablo. Oh boy, that sure was fun
Hope you guys enjoyed this video if you did smash like subscribe so we can be t-series and that's all Bros for now
What and that's all for now bros
ASS